اسرائليه جديده هنا في مخيم السموره في
مدينه ربح ال قطع غزه بعد قصف منك من قبل
طيران الحربي الاسرائيل كما تشاهدون
امامكم هنا في هذا المشهر خروج هؤلاء
المواطنين من تحت انقاض هذه البنايه بعد
ان تم انتشاله من قبل الطواقم الطبيه
الفلسطينيه ومن قبل المواطنين هنا في هذه
البنايه التي قصفت دون سابق انظار هنا في
هذا المخيم ومع هذا المساء
تزال عمليات الانتشال المتواصله
للمواطنين هنا في هذا
المنزل كنا نيران المشتعله ما تزال في
المنزل وايضا محاولات للبحث عن المفقودين
تحت الركام ركام هذه
البنايه ومازال المواطنين هنا يون على
الشهداء والمصابين
مع من الاطفال كما نشاهد معظمهم من
الاطفال مششاهد مؤلمه جدا وقاسيه لا اله
الا الله هذه طفله يتم انتشالها في هذه
اللحظات وما زال البحث مستمر عن اخرين هنا
اسفل هذا
المنزل مجزره كبيره هنا في هذا
المكان ارجعوا ارجعوا هنا
انتشال شخص اخر ايضا
يبدو
انه محاولات نقل من قبل المواطنين هنا في
هذا
المكان تم
انتشار من تحت الركام الجيش الاسرائيلي
يبدو انها
شه خليها خليها ربما على قيد الحياه هنا
انتشال شهيد اخر اشلاء في هذا المنزل من
قبل
المواطنين الذين يعاونون الطواقم الطبيه
في عمليات الانتشال كما نشاهد هنا في هذا
المشهد القاسي جدا لهؤلاء الشهداء الذين
قطعوا عشراء بفعل هذه
الغ وهنا ايضا محاولات كبيره من قبل
المواطنين البحث هنا اسفل ركام هذا
المنزل كما تشاهدون هنا عمليات البحث
متواصله اسفل الركام عدد كبير من الشهداء
والمصابين تبدد هذه الغاره على هذا المنزل
التي ادت الى ارتقاء هذا الكم الكبير من
الشهداء وكذلك المصابين المزاعم
الاسرائيليه بان مدينه رفح منطقه امنه ه
الشاعر لقناه الجزيره مدينه رفح